Okay, so we know about the first
idea in the acronym specs,
which is simplify code.
Let's talk about another one.
P stands for practicing kindness.
While preparing for this course,
I interviewed Jacque who,
as you've seen previously,
is an engineer at Udacity.
He said to me that it is
always important to remember
that the review is being provided
to a student who has invested
several hours of their
life into the project.
That is a sentiment we always want
to remember while writing reviews.
By the way, Stack Overflow
has some excellent guidelines
on how to provide constructive
feedback and be nice at the same time.
The link to that web page is
in the instructor notes and
I recommend that you bookmark it.
Now when you start doing reviews,
you will notice that the software will
allow you to highlight your feedback in
one of three categories,
Nitpicks, Awesome and Critical.
We strongly encourage that you
find areas in the students' code
that are awesome.
Students need to know how to improve,
but
they also need to know what
they're doing well currently.
So don't be shy to identify things
that are awesome as awesome.
In the next section, we will see
an example of a review highlighting
an awesome piece of code and
practicing kindness at the same time.